the mother's day weekend always a somber
occasion for a once prominent las vegas
family
40 years ago today the body of 18 year
old jamie walker was found in a wash
near lake mead
she had been raped and murdered well it
took 35 years before a suspect could be
identified and sentenced
and a rookie reporter named george knapp
was at the scene of the murder
four decades ago and has this up
eighteen-year-old jamie walker was a
deeply religious honor student
cheerleader and high school prom queen a
third generation civil rights activist
from a prominent west las vegas family
but on may 10
1981 mother's day her crushed body was
found in the las vegas wash
after being tossed from an overpass high
above she had been kidnapped from her
home and held for ransom
before being raped and murdered the
family had been awaiting news
but not this so my whole family was in
just
a panic trying to figure out what had
happened
gala walker thornton was only eight
years old at the time but she
idolized her cousin jamie and remembers
the grief that overwhelmed the walkers
especially jamie's mother eleanor i feel
like i'm letting my daughter down if i
don't find out what happened
think about her every day yeah
every day every day this is from a 2004
interview with eleanor walker she'd
reached out to the i-team
not knowing we'd been at the murder
scene on the day the body was found
23 years earlier from the beginning the
grieving mom worked the case herself
made copious notes stayed in touch with
metro cold case detectives and lobbied
news reporters to keep
jamie's story alive in 2011 she
accompanied us to the spot where the
body was recovered the first time she'd
ever been there
it was a difficult moment for everyone
present i just know it's impossible that
somebody around
here doesn't know something from the
beginning the person at the top of
eleanor's list of suspects was former
professional boxer willie the cannon
shannon
a hulking man who lived near the walkers
and who later served prison time for
raping another young woman
metro homicide detectives had a long
list of suspects
one that included shannon and police
records show that multiple generations
of cold case detectives
made jamie's murder a high priority i
think the suspects right in that file
cold case detective dave hatch was also
contacted by eleanor walker
years after the murder she didn't know
that hatch had also been on that
overpass the day
jamie was found hatch and his successors
pursued dna
evidence multiple times by 2010
the technology had advanced enough to
confirm the involvement of willie
shannon
he was arrested in florida and sat in
the clark county jail for more than five
years awaiting trial
on the day she was scheduled to give a
deposition in the case
eleanor walker's frail body finally gave
out
she died before she could see shannon
enter an alford plea
one in which he didn't admit guilt in
2017 nevada's parole board rejected
shannon's first request to be released
a few months later he was set free
anyway and returned to his family in
florida
well we were informed i got a letter two
days after they let him out and so that
was very offensive
um and just i've struggled with this
intensely my whole life but especially
as an adult
gala is a school counselor now and has a
daughter named jamie
mother's day is not a happy time for the
walker family
they suspect some of their neighbors
knew about shannon and about two
possible accomplices
but kept quiet perhaps the final chapter
of jamie's story has yet to be
written george knapp 8 news now